[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys and welcome to GameSpot live
I'm Cassidy and we've got some special
guests today we've got Jack Pattillo and
Trevor Collins
so you're here to play some Xbox one X
games on the Samsung Q LED TV which we
will get to you very shortly but first
we're gonna jump into some games we're
gonna start off with Assassin's Creed
Odyssey so you've been playing a lot of
zest I put quite a few hours into
Assassin's Creed so when I heard this is
one of the games unlike dibs
it's calling yeah I'll be jumping into
this one after that Trevor is gonna play
some fought 76 for the first time which
is exciting are you ready for that yeah
I love fallout I put tons of hours into
into Fallout series so I'm really
looking forward to getting a first look
at this game and getting in there
awesome and then we're gonna close it
out with some Forza horizon 4 so that'll
be fun so stay tuned for all of that
we're gonna play like 40 minutes of each
so let's jump into assassins right now
all right yeah so it looks like I'm
playing as Cassandra I will say this
isn't my save so I'm joking I'm gonna
ruin someone the game that's I've been
playing this on my own and the cool
thing about Assassin's Creed Odyssey
it's very much as RPG elements to it so
you can kind of play a good guy bad guy
I've been playing total white hat on my
account so I think I'm like this isn't
your safe so you can do whatever yeah so
we're gonna piss off a lot of people
here we go alright so we are in Mykonos
right now which is a really cool island
a lot of neat stuff over here there's a
hey Cassandra how you doing Wow yeah I
don't know this is uh looks heavy yeah
yeah it's pretty
gold yeah she's very agile for for
wearing all this armor Eagle oh gosh
also if you guys are hanging out in the
chat we are on youtube.com slash
GameSpot and I'm checking the chat there
so if you got questions for Jack or
Trevor let me know and I will pass them
over to them as Trevor all about the
stock market science and if you have any
homework questions Trevor will gladly
answer them for you I did some tutoring
for Millie daughter she was sitting on
the floor oddly enough doing some math
homework
nice man I love how big this world is
yeah like I think about say you love how
big this TV is there we go
that's Barnabas okay he's your easier
boat captain bases are he helps run the
boat and so I wonder without makeup
that's what I look like
down to the eye so about how far into
the game are we this is maybe about I
would say 30 to 40 percent in like at
this point so like there's the most
Assassin's Creed game there's kind of
like you know the people pulling the
strings behind the scene in this game is
a cult and so you're looking for
different cult members and so you kind
of go to different parts of the I like
different arts of Greece and find them
all scattered about and and right here
this is like what we've been alerted
there's a girl in Kira who sent a
message to our character say hey I need
your help
so we end up on the island and we're
helping and so now we're at Google
finder you play much Assassin's Creed
right I played a bunch of Assassin's
Creed's haven't gotten too far into this
game just yet yeah so here right oh here
we go so you guys I'm gonna ask for the
different things so you know I'm here
for arcades my job we're gonna do it we
can't do the job let's do it like that
it's good attitude
no no job all right so then we can ask
so cool thing is like you can do very
simple we're just tells you where the
locations of stuff are in the game or
you can ask me like okay like where
where the like where's the area what in
a minute sky yeah so you can dive more
into the lore if you were so inclined
yeah yeah so you can literally play
without a mini-map like like the top of
your screen you'll see it has like a
little bar where it kind of shows
everything is you can play without that
that you really want to get it means
okay not really I don't know all right
so yeah so now obviously have to go find
Kira and then and then another one
there's another guy whose name I forget
was that the pod what was like sort of
the pod arc is he's very good doctor is
the bad guy okay guys love Peleg just
detailed everything looks in this game
no beautiful so absolutely with all the
foliage now there's so many textures and
stuff I'm just thinking like you yeah
playing in flight guy keep looking at
that Bush
how'd you describe that balloon she goes
into down below all right this is like
someone put all that in the game like
someone spent time in this island from
what I understand I was actually lucky
enough I was streaming one time and a
guy who worked on a section of the game
I was on was in my chat being oh yeah I
hope you like this area design all of it
it's like wow so okay so here we go
target close to your target let's get up
a little bit higher eco this is your
your bird okay because starting in
origins the last Assassin's Creed game
yes they kind of took out the Eagle
vision and instead you literally have an
eagle and so this is eco dos so cool and
so you can pause him so like scan the
area there it is
we got some bad guys that I was like so
we gotta go track them down so we'll go
over here and see if we find Keita so is
that Eagle always just kind of hanging
out above you yeah yeah so I don't know
if you can actually spot him if you stop
moving for long enough he'll actually
land on your arm guy so oh wait was that
him there is over there yes no it's
definitely not an eagle oh I missed all
right and uh yeah real quick too so like
you know Assassin's Creed and like in
origins again they they sort of brought
in this whole idea of like a skill tree
and some now they really broke it down
specifically into abilities or depending
on how you play so there's an assassin
tree a warrior tree and a hunter tree so
hunters your bow and arrow
warriors your weapons like fighting an
assassin is yours until sneaky-sneak
looks like whoever whoever built out
this version was doing mostly warrior it
looks like yeah leans more warrior but
some of those assassins perks are ranked
up a bit like yeah this one here shadow
assassin yes that's when you use
sassanid someone sneaked up you do a lot
of damage to him I would probably go
assassin but I love the hand-to-hand
combat in the Assassin's Creed games
yeah and they definitely refined it too
well how would you typically play or
what's your personal say I go assassin
as much as possible yeah my thing is
typically I go assassin and then
you know once I mean Oh piss off
everyone they all come after me the nice
fight everywhere so I'll do my best to
kill as many people like in a hideout
and then then what soon as I everyone
that I go and like all right I guess
I'll fight you all but it's just so much
easier if you take them out one by one
all right
we're gonna meet someone thank you yeah
she has some confidence oh my goodness
you missed just one hair falls yeah
there we go there's Keita yeah she looks
like something out of black flag
so she runs a series of rebels fighting
it's put [ __ ] on these islands gotcha
can you tell have played this game a lot
yes oh we have lots of people won't you
have right now so their basic a Sandra
rocks the big fans of Cassandra she is
clearly the more interesting protagonist
yeah what's flexing their yeah yeah
Ubisoft actually made the Amazon Alexa's
they made and they made an Alexios Alexa
that was like red with a Spartan helmet
on it that's hilarious so this is put
our keys and that's his buddy over there
chopping some buddy up blowing up stuff
so he's bad as what he comes down it
didn't look like a good act he just did
there no I mean unless you like fire
destruction
and you so well I think you asked me
miss Dios is like helper pretty much
okay big dude in the background put some
pants on sorry here we go so what is the
yellow me I've noticed there's yellow
answers and white answers so white
answers basically give you more
information not whatever you're asking
ok yellow answers progressed got me to
talk about so if you want ask more about
that you can mm-hmm well it's kind of
we'll get to it cuz when I start
swinging start all right Cassandra she
she's she she's a woman of action she
just gets to move on yeah she was the
fight enough talk
she's a fighter now yeah let's get this
burger on the 1i plays very much love
her she's she's romanced everyone I
possibly could alright thank goodness
that guy's so big because he has to keep
helping his buddy up yes what are you
doing all right here let's go go I love
how like how dark the keys are that
young even torch it's so immersive yeah
the Torian that the lighting in this
game was like the way it's like yeah
volumetric lighting is I was called make
an awesome throw well okay and just
leave that there and fun nothing here
can burn yeah so it's a my rocks are on
fire this looks really pretty yeah we
already addressed this book crime asked
can you be a bad boy slash bad girl and
Odyssey oh yeah yeah yeah I mean you
still progress the story like there is
still a whole you know the pyramids have
to kind of follow a certain storyline
but you can definitely pick more jerkish
options is it a split between like
lawful good and chaotic good Hina yeah
can you be like chaotic neutral I mean
obviously you still have a storyline
like you said that you still have to
progress and come and compete against
the bad guys you know oh she's taking
arrows I wouldn't wait to fight these
guys oh yeah
guys come on all right jerks all right
what if they know I'm here
oh you head bottom it's knocked him over
all right sticking to the Cassandra's a
woman of action she just gets right in
their head but we don't have time for
these formalities of fighting there we
go chop chop chop
of course his first mission takes place
at night so it's super dark oh where she
got a horse foot where'd you get a horse
from I think the guy got off his horse
and now she's it's mine just took a
horse take that guy's horse that's okay
I think we're going here anyway so no we
gotta kill this guy - good thing there's
two of you y'all face her with a shield
and then you just shank him from Bob
good news it's on oh my god that sucks
to be that guy I always go ahead and
take that from you think give me some
gloves gloves hey they survived the fire
I here we go so look we gotta go these
dudes all right so we've got wall
something to see we've got bulrush there
we go so there's also skills you get
like so as you unlock like as you play
more you get abilities so there's a
shield break so like if someone has a
shield like this guy's got shield here I
can just go like give me that thank you
beat his ass down nice nothing more
demoralizing than being smacked with
your own machine and now it's my office
exactly Punk this what are your sorts
like on fire is there an effect on it oh
yeah just pulled that out of the fire so
you can actually that's one of the
things you can trigger where your sword
is
it's choreography the poorhouse
me and that Fenian soldier like yes you
I'm gonna swing this way stop streamers
you coordinated those moves but I mean
obviously someone has to articulate the
those movements is the high ground not
anymore
chop chop chop and dead finish mopping
our oh no no no let's just stay down
please
there we go get up and this is my Leone
is what's his name yeah also you are so
you were here so here we go so I was
Spartacus it's Martin he was I mean you
can say I was worried because
technically she was or even straight-up
lie and be like I know is that what the
justice yeah balance is what are you
waiting should we lie to him oh yes we
should lie he didn't even say your name
no she didn't know you that's full of
keys not like Bob hi I'm Tim all right
everyone dies Worf excellent yeah there
you go
he said some bows in the background
you're very poignant what was the whole
point poisonous poignant poignant yeah a
good pronunciation of a silent G lets
him know you mean business
oh yeah why not let's go to your hideout
go to the hideout get some marshmallows
drink some beers to be good time
question from chat what's the difference
from origins gameplay-wise that's from
one evil beast it's very similar if
you've played a if you played origins
it's very very similar as far as the
fighting style and stuff it's been
refined and tweaked a little bit I mean
like every Assassin's Creed like
everyone kind of takes what the last one
did and kind of improves on it
I like the origins a lot I really really
like Odyssey though like I don't think
it seems like every like everyone they
tried they kind of refine it just a
little bit more and the story's
fantastic is very interesting the voice
acting is great there's so much this
game is so dense these guys are happy I
mean even just in the short while that
we've been streaming we've met so many
different characters and we've already
opened up yeah quite a wide storyline
well that's a cool thing is like every
so like every kind of island there's
different like kind of plots yes like
this one it's Keira in full RK or not
but Keira foot arc Park is and whatever
this guy's name lead us yeah yeah so
it's kind of their story mm-hmm and you
kind of interact with them until you
finish off this island and you go on it
so it's like this is their stories you
can talk with them all right so should
we go with Kara or thalita this here oh
it's the latest artists
no disappointment snap off she goes
deeper into the cave we'll talk about me
men alright so here we go
death arrow as opposed to the wounding
error using a before you know the
happier another question from chat
what's the best or hardest achievement
you've got in the Assassin's Creed
series and I think perfect in Black Flag
was probably my I don't know any 1000
achievements but they're like there were
like skill challenges where it's like do
all these different things and there's
like a hundred of them if you got all
100 of them then at the then in your
boat you could actually replace your
crew with skeletons see literally a
skeleton crew and I honestly I don't
think it was a it wasn't an achievement
but like once you've completed all the
challenges took so many hours to do that
gave you the skeleton crew it has looked
awesome so I think that was by far my
best one what about you um I'm trying to
think I don't remember a lot of the
achievements that I went for because a
lot of them are so very difficult you
have to like perfect quite a bit and I
end up just getting too impatient to do
the missions as some of the achievements
request like they're looking for a lot
of immersive assassinations and like
stealth a lot of times I just get like
impe I'm a very running gun type of
player so I just pull up in there and
attack like right now I would have
already jumped on this guy let's see if
you do it right you can actually get it
whoa okay just right I'm stab them
not hurt him alive oh he's gonna start
out in like half health yeah man that
guy is strong I would've been like yeah
please don't do that again and run if I
had survived so this is a mercenary okay
so once you once you piss off enough
people you can see in the bottom right
corner I've got a meter the higher your
meter goes the more these bad guys gonna
come after you
there we go and if you kill them does it
lower it or does it no just brings on
the next level of them gotcha oh there
you go get him while he's down that's
good stuff I imagine there's countering
in this game like there were and the
other ones I mean kind of it's not that
new there's like dodging if you dodge
the right time yeah like more time so
there we go there's a mercenary killed
there you go
and he'll usually give you pretty good
gear to come on can you loot them hey
guys don't mind me it's okay there we go
that's one else got a new one
some money's so yeah like these guys
will show up and they'll start harassing
you it's a huge pain in the ass let me
go ahead and sign this this is my
healing ability there you go necie have
eight wheel or you have eight things you
can see the bottom left corner there
I've got my the top one is like an
assassination stab so basically knocks
off a whole lot of health real quick
okay left one is a brake shield so you
can make some she'll off the right one
is smart you kick so you can do people
and the bottom was like a heel gotcha so
that's really good to have but like
we'll see here let's see we find this
I'll share the kick works where'd that
go because they take that go come here
buddy oh there's another go just went
limp that's how you get mother you let
me see if I can boot something off
something real quick yes I could boot
Kira can you like whistle get like kind
of like coax people to the edge of
something oh yeah maybe drop some coin
you're close to the untracked target oh
there we go
okay oh that was a bad guy
I'll be like you buddy
well I'll be with anyway back up what a
recharge a little bit what happens if
you kick a horse they kick back oh man
that horse is like I heard you talk
about kicking horses I'm gone field oh
okay sprawled let's go talk to Kyra who
takes the long nap I'm track target over
on periscope gumbo King so what game is
this we're playing Assassin's Creed
Odyssey and we've got Jack Pattillo and
Trevor Collins from achievement hunter
here they're playing on the Xbox one X
and the Q LED TV which is brought to you
by Samsung and I'll talk about a little
bit later and we're gonna play for about
maybe let's see twenty more minutes and
then we're switching over to fall at 76
okay so here we go she's like hey are
you working the rebels now not the cold
Eggman Assassin's Creed the characters
lines the eyes those are good they
convey a lot of emotion no very well
they don't look empty which is what I
appreciate you know for murder yeah so
the whole thing was dogs in this game
game great game great game
I don't even pet him or not he's looked
at minus points hey booj booj lady I'd
like to trade my Eagle before this dog
so putting green what do you put prints
and I think that might be a dead person
you think so gives away the pile of
bones the flies yes so what we can do
there's a whole I mean there's a whole
series of steps that get you to like the
final guide to put our keys to actually
fight him what I may just end up doing
is just go over to kill him because it's
gonna take a little bit of time he's
also a lot more powerful right now okay
because he can weaken them by doing
various things and then maybe a little
bit easier to kill but if you were
wanting a challenge and you got to this
island you could technically go after
him pretty soon just run straight in and
kill him like I can go kill him right
now oh man maybe before we rats will try
that yeah one's gonna take it'll take a
little bit of time
yeah I can I can spoil a little bit of
excited I'm pretty well both you're
standing in water you're gonna ruin your
shoes having my feet are resting a
little water is one of those things that
you always look at and yeah face like
you you can almost like judge the
graphics just off of it because look at
it well I'll tell you what we'll do the
oldies after this conversation here well
go try to kill the bad guy okay and then
I'm gonna jump on the ship and then
we'll go first all right and also just
turns out we found out that Keira the
girl who hired us I put marquees as
their death bed turns out that she's
like she's a secret daughter of put our
keys does she know this Kieran is not
okay that right now this woman's crazy
I lost fine yeah there's a whole thing
it's fun because in this whole quest
line you can romance Keira mmm-hmm and
you can also romance the lettuce too
and the same time yeah oh you can do
both but then if you're a man's Kyra and
then you end up killing this guy the
lettuce is like I was supposed to kill
him like and he's like you've taken
everything from me you took you took you
took a the kill I'm supposed to have you
also took money you took Kira as well
it's like you've taken everything all
right so let's go let's go see when you
find what's-his-name
here we go it's gonna be pretty tricky
here because uh yeah again you're
supposed to like weaken them quite a bit
show yourself a number of people there
limit to how many people you can
highlight in and one go with a Karissa
no name of the bird you caught echo
those heroes it's like I get er oh okay
alright so scan around make sure we got
a good look at it here oh hey guys
alright so that's a whole new way to
like stealth into these places let's see
if let me check my abilities real quick
because there's a couple that I could
definitely use mhm
and then reassign my abilities here
heroes strike that's the one I want
right there um we'll swap this one with
okay Sata's we're gonna get really kick
for now kick is fun but we're going for
function yeah we're gonna force sneaky
sneak um okay so yeah dude there
I like the threatening bodies kind of
just laying out up front just strapped
the coast okay good kick opportunity
it's only a three foot ball oh my
goodness she's pretty brutal
alright no I take this here well we
didn't kick but we can at least do the
same thing I love a good rag doll yeah
okay so we got that one there that's a
captain over there so you can see by the
yellow shield yeah he's a little bit
stronger the problem is we probably
can't kill ow ow ow Oh
you probably can't kill poor darkus in
one stab because he's a leader he's
basically had guys so it'll be a fight
and the more guys we kill around him
before we fight him the less it's get it
less difficult it'll be makes sense
summer so we'll go around the first
floor stealthily picking them off try to
wipe out as many as possible sounds good
take this guy with the funky hat
oh he's is he weak already what's going
on with him oh I see the red was showing
how much damage you would do you think
yeah was I did a like ultra attack
basically sort of one cycle FeO the
other guy can stay in the pool well
she's got good balance okay so let's
sneak up on this guy and see if we can
kiss he pink oh oh hey guys but my mate
don't my washing around okay we're good
we're good okay I missed that guy oh oh
he's investigating is he gonna stab the
flowers to see what oh whoa very good
catch oh oh yeah he's gonna kill him
here we go nice okay question from Bob
Jones what was the hardest fight in
Odyssey man I just fought the Minotaur
and man that was a tough one there's
also there's a boar in the game so
there's legendary animals in the game
there's a boar who's like the first
legendary animal you fight and my god is
that boar a huge pain in the ass he is
so difficult it's it's unbearable
freakin boring I spent I spent a good 45
minutes on him cuz what he does is he
fights you a little bit and then I'll go
with my call and reinforcements like
other boars and then we've got a we got
a mercenary nearby I'm actually pay him
off real quick see I even paying off my
batting gods right there so that way
it'll be a little bit easier but yeah
this boar he'll the whole call in
reinforcements and then you have to
fight them while trying to fight the
boar oh it's it's so difficult
let's see if we get up here and be
sneaky sneak okay yo you're squatting
did he go to the bathroom I think he's
looking I think he's writing some oh
yeah he said it looks like he's sitting
on a table all right other guys around
side though just dangled foot off the
off the roof and he'll be like what's
that
and you'll grab my whistle oh yeah
that'll get him upstairs
your buddy come here with your nice hat
come here come on
no not both of you just one just one I
only want one I only want one of you
darkus go away oh okay well maybe we're
fighting start she's dead oh wait wait
he's thinking about it there's this
buddy his buddy okay so they travel in
twos they do move in herds hey buddy it
hurts let's go all right sneaky very
good balance very good balance I'm part
cat let's just rid ourselves of this
nuisance oh hey buddy oh hey don't don't
mind me
oopsies and you guys coming up those
stairs I think sooner he's near the
bottom of those stairs
Oh oh boy oh yeah we are nice moon side
so we got put our keys here all right
here's the cruel all right eCos is
distracting the guard your eyes all
right we got a few of them now so let's
let's do this let's find a nice spot to
fight him yes a good roof all right come
on boys you first question from good man
damn what do you think will be the next
AC game they they alluded to feudal
Japan for a while which i think of me
plenty freakin round that would be
incredible
my personal head Canon with assassin's
creed is that they're gonna do I don't
know he did half your healthy
oh yeah this is it's so interesting cuz
I'm not built this isn't normally how I
like play these characters so like this
is much anyway um my personal head Canon
is that a lot of the stuff in the movie
soffit universe
so like watchdogs and
and what else now I'm in the military
most six like all these different games
they're all the same universe and so I
think there's gonna be a modern-day
Assassin's Creed Wow that will be at
like it'll turn out like watchdogs
actually the whole time you've been
you've been an assassin you just never
knew it very interesting whether or not
all these guys gonna kick my butt
because there's nods to it in in various
games they all nod to each other's
existence and stuff but to have it come
out and in a storyline would be very
very cool
alright so oh my gosh how does he just
take arrows like that it's got a strong
face just like ding-ding right to his
forehead trying to take a look he goes
home his wife he sees a tough day at
work he's just got arrows sticking out
of his head oh very tough day oh okay I
think oh nice I took out a little bit of
damage from can weaken your shield yeah
you don't have to say picking off these
guys might be your best bet and then
just whittling away at him your Health's
recharged again Wow your ability anyway
in that shield I get both of them Wow so
there's an ability where if you dodge an
attack you'll get like they'll slow down
time oh nice I don't know if I'm just
missing it or what but wow is that maybe
an ability that this this particular
build hasn't opened up yet oh yeah baby
there we go okay that's that's great
that's very useful for this fight there
we go okay so now we're down just one
guy although it looks like an immersion
err he's on his way to yeah Nora the
snow leopards coming hey Nora
sounds like this this series has always
been great at making you feel like a
boss because you can go up against you
know a leader here and all of his all of
his uh his guys and still make it out of
cow but it's still it's a challenge but
I think you still come out on top going
in against like five other needs it's
now I'm fighting a leopard - why not
mercenary showed up no ow
I'll get out of there get out of there
you're stuck on my sorry cat I love cats
but you got to die okay alright put our
keys you and me out no Snow Leopard just
go away
look the crazy thing is even if I kill
her I know it's gonna show up really
yeah I guess I just gotta kill the dark
is like an overpowered tack there all
right Nora what are you Nora
I got your health ability back birds
coming in birds leaving again Jesus put
our keys back up nice good job nor he
was the enemy against the other enemy so
that ability there is that my top one
that is a good one it basically does all
of your assassins damn interesting
that's good before he could even
complete this yeah he attack oh he's so
close to death just one arrow make it
like this shoot me in the hand
alright let's just what Aaron we've got
some new viewers in chat asking about
our guests this is Jack Pattillo and
Trevor Collins from Achievement Hunter
and they're here currently playing
Assassin's Creed Odyssey and they're
playing on the Xbox one X on the Q LED
TV brought to you by Samsung so this is
my playing on this TV house how's this
experience it looks super awesome and
from what I understand your guys gonna
give us this TV put that in my pocket my
75 inch pocket no it looks awesome and I
guess the blacks in this are super nice
that's the one thing like oh I was gonna
say the TV actually complements when you
went into the cave it actually looked
like a cave to the point where you
needed to pull out your torch to to move
forward so it helps with that immersive
experience which is really awesome it's
got the 4k HDR and that's I think it's
the auto game mode cuz it automatically
switches to the best gaming settings for
you which is really convenient for me
settle yourself
yeah okay Snow Leopard I need you to die
because I really have to progress the
story don't you understand this you need
to know this something all right now and
there we go okay so he's kneeling over
here cuz they were you gonna talk yep
yeah okay that's what I thought so I
have finished I did get out of the
flight there we go not messing around
not much of a talk was that there we go
so nicely yeah so we got the Lu cultists
as well so again how it works out I can
show you
so the cultists like this is all of the
people you have to fight like a man and
so we have a lot of information about
this I bought a bunch of them but yes
like as you kill them you get more
information than like you can reveal
them so like this you can like see
information about this guy see if we got
any clues like some of them are on map
anyway it's really neat like this so
ultimately if you kill all these guys
the mercenaries in the game like this
you can see all these these are the
people I've been fighting and like the
more you kill them the more bonus stuff
you get their ability tree but let's go
to the ship now let's check out the
ships will wrap up how much time we got
left take out that pig budget about five
more minutes of this if you want to
figure out what you want to do for the
last of assassins and then we're moving
on to fall at 76 okay cool I'll head
over to the ship so you can see what it
looks like in the water looks beautiful
and it looks awesome let's DVD 2 so
there we go so we killed the darkest so
yeah you're all saved Keira happy your
dad's dead and so head on over here oh
we leveled up as well
nice you're welcome to over savegame
this is there's engravings there's so
much stuff in this game now to really
like make it exactly what you want jump
across this Oh forward of that hey
Louise oh man oh man
you gotta call my boat okay how are you
doing it as the waves in that it's like
you dressed uh is your boat masked and
you can upgrade it throughout the game
you can get different crews so like you
can like have like Spartans on the ship
and stuff so that way your ship-to-ship
combat you know you can take on bigger
ships yeah for supplies I guess get
places faster I soon so here we go nice
yeah so I do like the idea that there
isn't a need for a wheel because of the
guys paddling down below you just yell
your commands and the ship kind of just
does it
you guys don't happen here's this a
pretty pretty finale for you here yeah
look at that you just look at the water
it looks so good in this game it's great
and then every now and then you'll get
like dolphins dick next to you and stuff
and let's go dolphin watching there's a
whales that'll sail next yeah take some
away olivewood do you fight the other
ships yeah yeah you can actually there's
all kinds of fighting stuff seeing take
out the aliens and stuff all right
the the Owls are the Athenians and red
ones are the Spartans also pirates too
you have to fight so goal there you go
some assassins creed for you sweet I did
my part
yeah trap we're gonna take a first look
at 76 yeah the game so alright so fall
on 76 what are you hoping to see here
I'm I'm just like I really love
open-world games and where you can kind
of just choose your own adventure with
it like with a bunch of what whether
it's the main story or a bunch of little
stories I like to experience all of it I
always like complete all the mini
stories before it can finish the final
arc so I'm just looking to just get
immersed and get lost in all the
different sizes how much time did you
put into it fought for it oh my goodness
uh I I don't know if that game keeps
track of for you but I'd have to guess
upwards of like 50 to 60 hours at least
so you're ready for but but yeah
cool yeah I'm really curious what the
multiplayer in this game cuz like we do
a lot of multiplayer stuff of
Achievement Hunter and we've already
talked about like alright so we're gonna
build up like a city together like how
I gotta work like I know yeah it's kind
of like squads of like four but then you
can have like 24 people or 16 people per
server so it's like I'm curious if we
can maybe we can work it out where it's
like oh we can actually end up all on
one server together I don't know it's
gonna be it's gonna be very interesting
but I haven't played any of this yet so
I'm curious to watch Trevor play
yeah just even looking at these loading
screens I'm just like I'm super exciting
yeah all the nostalgia is coming back I
just want to be back in the Fallout
universe just seems like it just throws
you right in so I started the game
yesterday and I like there was no
instruction it's just like hey you're
here like Who am I where am i what am i
yeah why is it you start inventing
something so we're gonna spend the next
30 minutes designing your character as
far as I know that's how fallout begin
he's been 40 minutes making a character
looks like Michael Jackson and then you
go that's the game see if you guys have
any questions for Trevor or Jack about
this game or anything let me know when
the chat we're over on youtube.com slash
games about we're also on periscope
right now take a chat questions lots of
stuff and we're playing on the Xbox one
X this is fall at 76 and we're also
playing on the Q LED TV brought to you
by Samsung this is a very large
beautiful TV shot of the TV right now
Alex yeah God how can how can we take
this it'll look great on my wall of it
all right here we first contact find the
overseers CA MP okay don't you ever do
it well I'm gonna immediately go into
this place to start looting all right
all right I gotta get back into the
fallout control scheme see what we got
here it looks good oh I'll let pipe I'll
take a lead pipe all right so we can see
we've got kind of gotten angry I like my
party a little party hat on you know
okay so it doesn't look like I have you
don't have a lot you don't have a lot
yet so I'm just trying to sort out where
and maybe I think I have a cinephile
here
you're left where we are right there so
it looks like a Blood Pact I'll take
speed piping gonna be part of your camp
now let's see so this same file and so
you've gotta get this sort out kind of
where we're at
yeah I think this just came out
yesterday right I think it opened up
yesterday so oh oh hey buddy I like your
playing he's got a plan those plans job
offer together we'll take a hatchet and
a stim pack there's a note said Java and
I'm gonna read the job opportunity you
sick of cutting wood over there yet I've
been working what's happening getting
hit by something tick you're let hype
out okay we're shotgun I've got a load
real quick word where'd you go what's
that blood serious oh I have some
radiation damage
oh they're quick little guys or tip oh
come on hey the advance can you hold on
I'll check after wait that's nutty the
first one oh he's so quick yeah please
stop Oh a nice fold no it's full of my
blood you give it back okay
tick ones he took your black this is
mine all right what's up all right let's
see what we got here
so here's our mat how big is this map do
you back that's about as far back as I
can go but I can scan around quite a bit
wow I like this idea that he's just got
a map out in the middle were you ever
set it's like looking very closely in
all right so now let me let's see if I
can a third person there we go
I'm gonna get used to these controls
just bear with oh okay emotes yes yes
looks like Nick soretro yeah all right
art there you go
swap over to that so I can swap yeah so
gonna keep in mind there's just
impactors there's my stem pack so right
on the d-pad a stim pack you have your
five more yeah keep mine this is an open
server right so if something if you
might run into somebody you decide to
either be friends with them or they're
gonna murder you so let's see overseers
camp I'm sorry let's go back to the map
here that's right down this one there's
a vault is north ear the vault
yeah question from chat favorite Fallout
game uh I'm definitely gonna have to say
for cuz it's the one I put the most time
into but I also put a buttload of time
into just building with one of our other
employees with Matt Bragg just coming up
with just goofy ideas on how we can like
come up with really crazy stuff within
their their creator oh man my my
endurance is not great I'm just taking
the road I played a lot of new Vegas
no that was my jam I'm a big fan of
Vegas in general like the city of Vegas
so new Vegas kind of made sense for me
so no Ryu Peter run out it's just gonna
like kind of kiss the edge of my okay my
stamina there so this is the camp over
here it looks like
oh I just I love all the like kind of
futuristic retro Yago that fallout has
to offer sort of Jetsons style
hey buddy let me check on the mail real
quick what's this guy doing you uh
petrified corpse you didn't make it far
if you were running that was nothing
let's petrol on it in there hold on let
me oh I searched him I guess I oh no I
gotta get out okay moving in there it's
like Friday 13th Venice yeah uh yeah try
to peek up in there you can do this or
you can't we'll hit you there oh good
nice sneak attack 2x damage nice nobody
upstairs hello oh you're up here you
forgot his skin embarrassed yeah bad bad
move okay bobby pins
good for locking a baseball or bass was
it was a bass pack of cigarettes
- that's like they need stacked it all
the stuff like I'm gonna say I've got my
blood sacks and I like pie originally my
lead pipe yeah all right let me make
sure I don't leave any scrap unkept I
will just sit yeah how about have a
little seat there we go and look at the
back of his his undead oh they'll need
some rounds pipe pistol Plus thank you
thumbs up actually let's see I do want
to I do want to confused no angry
miscellaneous follow me oh I like that
trade talked all right I'm going to say
hello and goodbye to the young man we
just I guess you have to be standing on
it throughout yeah okay all right let's
get out he's fine the overseers camp we
should be pretty close and we'll check
just real quick oh no
so okay this map is a lot bigger than I
thought yeah
quite a bit I thought had gone down the
whole road but it turns out no you seen
your little mini compass on yeah you're
right
okay so you've built a lot of stuff in
for you looking forward to building
stuffing in this one absolutely yeah
one of my favorite mechanics was like
just crafting and and just building I
almost didn't see you you blend it in a
little fiend
oh those a three-headed possum yeah well
300 meat Oh possible old possum yeah I'm
curious about the the building aspects
in this cuz this you like build stuff
and then move like you can look like
pick it up and move it elsewhere I'm
just gonna so I'll just get some scrap
I'll load up with a bunch of stuff you
know I'm very particular i hoard a lot
of stuff but I gotta get familiar with
this game this iterations crafting
mechanics to know what is the more
valuable stuff because otherwise you get
encumbered with lead pipes and wrenches
whereas you kind of want more like
things like clocks and and and scrap
that can offer you more versatile you
know I think in the future let pipes
will be the currency they will be oh
it's a nice car you got there I'll give
you a three-letter guy he's a person
there there's a man here and you're a
level 14 want to be friends wave Adam
alright invite the team like to trade oh
I don't hold on there you go wave hello
hi murder you it's true what else gonna
go what else can I say
heart love listen I just got I go to
eleven his first date why you gone right
at him if I do it you know what you're
right
much better put this away I forgot oh
okay you know maybe maybe we person live
yeah let's scraps my head real quick got
some extra scraps we hold why is grapple
junk oh that's good call
oh yes that challenge good scrap junk to
produce resources plus ten things what
is this long can't play this okay bill
to relook at your camp by opening your
pip-boy impressing leftover okay well
that's what I did oh there we go okay so
that's it so right there so I guess that
green dome around you yeah there you are
my office and then you can drop it and
then rebuild it I do I do like it here
but it says red we also figure that's
probably where people oh you know I bet
no no I said that this is where people
are coming to complete this mission so
you probably don't to be too close to
that let's take a look at wait hold on
cancel so I can take a look at the map
there there's a guy oh there's some
people down here quietly over see you on
the fly was where should I put my camp
Jack what do you think maybe let then
thought on this thing yeah this bird
yeah alright cool look good we'll go
that way up the hill well have a good
vantage public rested craft a piece of
armor craft the weapon and then you get
you those missions so I see crafts I
like it alright armor armor
well they're just piece so we need some
leather to get it's pretty much missing
leather yeah tag for search rights there
that's right stick yeah click and right
stick an old tag for surgery yeah what's
the best thing I can I guess chest piece
but I need more steel for that so
there's one left foot this one looks
like it's the closest to do another tag
leather for search and then what else do
I need
oh look at that okay more cloth I mean I
want I need this American patriots I
don't just want it I need it okay and
then you need to make a weapon too
okay so let's go back there must be
different different craftable items and
where there might be a different thing
we might add different stations like a
weapon that is the outfit probably show
weapon orange there we go one meal a
pipe guns throwing weapons it's okay
we're very far off from crafting some of
these Souls and melee melee we got
leather and wood for a board uh let's
see
a geared to rubber anyone here some
throwing weapons there nicely that's uh
that's good until some of these there
goes all of our steel though so we'll
have to get more steel and more cloth
okay to make our armor we have leather
and stuff for that exit very well done
okay I have to be smart now pairs are
made in the weapons workbench wonder if
we can repair anything that we've got
right now or let's see yeah listen why
don't we go like over to your area and
so you can drop the bill to camp it's
gets covered yeah yeah let's get up here
I think I'm going further than oh yeah
here's my custom marker oh nice so much
so far so flower it is getting very dark
out very strong there's a lot what
gathers log collect wood one-on-one nice
challenge complete we can eat wood for
that too you can make a board oh yes
just need leather still need leather and
then I can make a piece of armor and my
board all right what you to do I took a
log of meat board I just go around to
everybody in the server you like my
boards myself I like I'm just I'm all
wonky
bro good you got splinters all in your
no parent I don't know if I can mind
because I can you did my bare hands you
mind the crap out of that she's punching
at the rocks you like my horse it hurts
so bad
mm all right here we go there's cresting
the hill here oh there's a dude frozen
dude I don't want to break those guys I
know that's bad news
fire oh okay so I'm put my marker right
around Oh recruiter gutsy Oh where's
that
that's a yearling oh oh oh it's that
deer I think yo you got [ __ ] leather
pardon me oh you got leather oh you're
right hold on
you scared it I don't want a snake do
you go down too far no hold on oh it's
almost dead right you're right I lost it
I lost him I think he ran hurting ah
dang it
well shucks I think we're just gonna go
put let's put our camp down yeah well
we'll look for something with leather in
the future after we it's a pit boy all
right oh that's an existing location
okay rad snagged oh oh oh oh Trevor
you're such a bad shot
all right I miss left how did I die
that's before you didn't that one time
and then we shot that person just try to
say hi and I've at Stonem all right
question from Jordan and chat what bill
do you usually go for and fall out I
definitely go for sharpshooting but then
I also like the the perks of all the
different things you can go for I love
doing charisma because I love
I hope talking to people like just like
bullying them out of like extra stuff if
I can get like there was a time where I
was just I I calm down people like that
were just in an argument but then
they're like okay okay ma'am just calm
down and then I use my charisma to be
like no give me no give me some
okay so here you go now everything in
your store yeah it's a love being laid
out with dialogue but then also yeah
being able to like pull out a sniper and
like that people from afar is pretty
nice flower right so okay we got to go
to a non-existing well I'm just gonna
really go over see you roll it okay
let's yeah let's see what's over there
we can put down a camp later so I
imagine it'll trigger some stuff yeah
cuz we're up in the and the sticks here
I'm tired West Virginia something
something song sounded song that's weird
camps this other's electricity
doo-doo-doo-doo you're up high dude yeah
I wanted to put my camp up on a mountain
I guess I kind of ignored the path while
coming up and now it's become more
perilous to get back there yeah but all
the people that's one of the my favorite
things about this game is among the side
missions and stuff is just wandering
because they put so many different just
like a little hidden locations like
there's that gazebo just right up there
just locations and people that you can
come across and now that there's other
people playing in your server just
become a little bit more interesting to
see where other people are kind of
gathering or yeah
searching for things or whatever what's
interesting to like the idea of like
there's other humans it adds that extra
element to it it's like are they gonna
be friendly like there's beaver why not
I'm curious about that how like because
there's like no they cease in the game
now right so what's gonna be like when
they're interacting with humanity
because they are actually human Green
Country Lodge almost levelled up in
ninety years my something away why does
that where you add diseased
okay now I need to figure out why I'll
just pop you okay
kill different kinds of creatures we
figure out like which which button was
the VATS because it's not triggering
again let me click in the thumbstick
here yeah that's sprinting Crouch try
your bumpers gonna ask the chat to chat
let us know because we picked up this
game we started right on mid mid games
oh yeah we early tutorial my first time
dropping in 276 and then it's also on a
save file here host alright
overseas log a cardboard standee okay
well pip-boy go to items notes first
time I see them I bet screwdriver
alright so in the pip-boy for notes its
items its underneath there you and there
we go go to notes from there very good
the hints were over forget alright so we
got a plan for a cardboard standee water
pump looks good propaganda flyer crappy
and looked and looked okay you should
make a stand e let's see if I can craft
in here what do you got we've got three
warm money that's as good as money
dasu Ben Amin alright thank you sir oh
he's guys in Iraq okay what do you got
he's a volunteer bot I can trade with
them okay so what does he have
does he perhaps have there he's got a
baby rattle I'm gonna go over what he's
got
hey mo miscellaneous his arrow weapons
favorites where's the stuff that I'm
searching for you need you needed steel
other leather but I how do I get his
stuff
maybe pygmies pick some in left and
there are you okay so used to liked his
stuff yeah it's a glass spring would
rubber do steel and wood oh this is a
nice cheap source of Steel so I'll take
that okay you give him twenty your parts
drink to avoid negative effects you need
drinks okay then why didn't it except
the firm purchase okay
oh I only have two I thought for some
reason I saw 200 but that's his money
before but you're you're wealthy and
friends for a month inference yeah I
mean I don't have my receipt but MedX
alright cool
okay not real quick oh it's gonna live
out here I don't let's see plug pack I
got some medics they were just wasn't
five minutes increase hungry he needs
reached do you have purify water you can
drink I do it there's some red X I need
some of that
it's mortar oh you said what I got on my
corner there you go
increasing and let's see if we got some
water dude oh look I pulled that it show
that out you can put that down there
craft a piece of armor get the Supply
Drop show also register as a volunteer
so be registered volunteer maybe the
computer you can do it okay where's that
computer at me
responders database someone said you
have to listen to holotapes to get to
the next mission telling us okay guest
thank goodness I didn't know my password
we always give that bad
patients metals Chris metals : like okay
okay okay oh I don't have just print
plane I mean about my flyer I'll show
this to people water safety report okay
alright Walter cannon Colonel I'm just
gonna take club oh my goodness alright
sly Oh shocked that's funny okay let's
get a paramedics outfit on
oh he's busy because you're here oh it's
like a hipster I'm trying to find West
Virginia hipster take that coffee cup
you throw the coffee cup out Oh Oh these
guys do their thing
sup guys yo yo free money okay gimme
gold analyze obvious they're waiting for
their turn Oh log it in here
access denied so you need them all you
need me along here well as your training
speak with that said Ben Emil registered
the self-serve thing so see if you
register chemistry station what's the
thing on the left this one here it's
fighting with your right I mean he
pulled out a stick and hit him with it
Oh hold on oops we're good
Hobbes here no fight unwise whatever's
beating people with a stick no not cool
oh no no bad he's angry you're upset
let's see it's let's see it see let's
see no angry why are you angry
all right let's see if the registers
volunteer now okay didn't say uh-oh
there's a sleepy shredder sorry let me
get rid of my custom marker because it's
really throwing me up here
do place marker try placing a new one
there your move marker okay registers
volunteer get the Supply Drop volunteers
over this way okay so it's outside yeah
okay that's why I was a little confused
there we go that's full so whatever if
um if flute is unique to individuals or
if we all like went into a place and
there was a first-aid box if we'd have
to split it okay ah yes boom here we go
I don't need a directory right now it's
completed now there's a Supply Drop
you know music here hundred bucks my
favorite song you know what it is we're
gonna make games keeps my hat unhappy in
place of music alright cool
montage of Queen and David Bowie in the
Beatles of Michael Jackson Supply Drop
here oh nice just take the flare off
blood pack pitchfork flare gun
leather left arm the thing I was gonna
make oh come on come on oh we can go
shooting hey still hitting you oh no I
need a knot you're right yeah I ducked
and punched a dirty pillow nice how are
you holding that those his binky he's
had alright so now you can locate Kesha
McDermott all right oh you can search
for her location in the system this
guy's going for this Brahmin oh you saw
me no good you came at me I'm sorry
I need that leather you know it's her
mother Oh down he goes all brown a gun
and y'all hide and we're the wooden this
guy go that's okay hey sleepy what's in
the sleepy shredder we're friends right
I'm pretty sure we got oh no it's
another thing I like to do is just like
free kick up all the reading I can pick
up because sometimes it opens up a
little quests see just outside flight
which tired parking lot delicious and
free cooking lessons alright alright
okay locate Ke$ha McDermott alright I
should probably craft a piece of armor
to get rid of the problem west so
there's a there's a people directory in
here that I could probably look her up
with a cache and Dermott there we go
no dollar sign on her exactly yeah it's
still me alright monitoring water safety
conducting ongoing hydrology alright I
found it
complete search for Ke$ha along the
river nearby sounds good I imagine she's
probably not doing great
I'll give her a second search for Ke$ha
we can track this quest for a little bit
I just want to be focused laser focus
nice down Imran and chat said ludus for
each person if you're in a group and you
and your team kill a monster you guys
can get the loot but if your team kills
the monster but you don't hurt it you
don't get any loot god yeah so so it's
typical party system you want to make
sure that you put some damage in
responders paramedic jumpsuit look Jack
who like him now look one of us I'm here
all your paramedic can make you bleed
and give me a blood alright let's let's
get over here Kesha don't stop make it
pop it's so dark okay water testing kit
am I just taking this from Kesha story
survivor story buff out listen money
test the sample of water from the river
you got it oh oh oh yeah again let me
step out of the water turn dirty water
to boil water at a cooking station or to
remove the risk of disease oh yeah we
had we had to deal with that in Austin
not too long ago
yeah yeah way to boil our water because
it flooded and made everything horrible
so I got soups are you doing that keep
bringing that thing out um so let's see
here what was it that I wanted testing
kit there yeah
you cannot equip it so let's see how I
am you might have to go to a station
first of all you're gonna love oh look
at that I'm gonna level up what makes
you special Trevor I'm gonna go for some
endurance just number one take three
percent now let's see charisma when you
are on a team you gain five experience
more which is great
stimpaks or store for two percent well
that's super nice intelligence right now
is a good good way to go agility is
always nice action points or generate
future I'm gonna do that I do like
running around as an explorer I like my
action points okay now oh there we go
collect dirty water do not drink okay
test testing waters an open water is in
fact contaminated just a sample I stood
in it I could have figured it out the
pain I was in my skin is burning okay
let's see I'll do this to get some
health get some stamina thank you thanks
your left is your marker right there
okay I see so it's probably a test test
sample water from the flower woods water
pumps that bridge
Wow look at that
that night sky oh man I just ended up
staring at the night sky for this the
stream well you can see more stars
because there's less light that's how it
works
yeah I wonder doesn't it doesn't
accurate sky pattern oh let's see if you
see any constellation guess it's
probably no the thing is is that there's
so many extra stars like you said
because the the lack of civilization and
lights that I want to be hard to see
those extra bright lights I'm sure about
the Colorado went out there like the
middle of night get out in the mountains
it's collect and uh yeah that's really
really nice you can see all the stars a
bunch of cool photos
water is contaminated Jack don't drink
it okay so now analyze the water Justin
kids results in Kesha's lab
at all don't stop make it pop some of
them something
there's no commerce Virginia all right
at some point I should eat it's getting
there you know okay double Devon well Oh
tripped on something you fell over
something hello Devon I said yes he's
like what you want a team up how long
like my hat I got I put also I put
glasses on okay I'll make you smarter
yeah it's like you like to party but
you're also serious yes exactly
you're the mullet of people if you're
just tuning in we're playing fallout 76
right now you are looking at Trevor
Collins and Jack the tillow on the
screen they're here to play some games
on the Xbox one X on the Samsung 2018 Q
LED TV which you're looking at right now
it's 75 inches we're going to talk a
little bit more about that after we play
fallout 76 but you know we're just kind
of exploring of this Trevor's first time
playing this is our first time watching
the game so yeah we're all learning at
the same time if you've got any
suggestions in chat we're over on
youtube.com slash GameSpot let us know
what you'd like to see absolutely real
quick I'm gonna see if I could not use
any of the stuff I picked up in this
place to just show it coffee cup one cat
you know I'm about it cuz that was
basically his combat knife though and
hold on to that man I I literally picked
some of these things up in front of the
man it's like okay I will give you one
cap for collecting that out of me give
to handle that pipe IPO two hatchets we
got two of them you're right it's great
out farm yourself and then one cat
wasn't even worth it
mountain honey that's my nickname no I
don't want to sell this so you're pretty
hot pistol oh I got a lot of old Tyson
Souls
cruise the wolf said I want to see a
monster fight alright alright let's back
out of here monster fight after I feel
this way boil that water okay start need
a little brighter outside that's good
you're weak right now dude very weak
cooking station here we go
let's see school I do want to cook some
of the meat I made let's grow some of
this hmm
awesome opossum bacon all right boiled
water I'll get some extra water there
make it to you while I'm here
okay check in with us also every kiosk
okay look that are back in that exit
there we go and the Sun is coming up so
I'm gonna see where I'm walking it's
gonna be either a massive game dude
self-serve kiosk wait was that oh I
wasn't following my chat my tracking
point you had a follow your stars man I
stars oh that's a ceiling just like was
it night sale
check all in tier status go get pricks
are you reasonable for leveling up quick
you can fast travel to events from your
map now nice sweet first things first
there's things first I'm a realist okay
first of all thirst things I'm going to
see again watering some food though so
much water you don't need I want water
and let's see i grilled the radroach
mead a little bit of rads to it but you
know what you know you do what you gotta
do
did I cook the meat no I didn't just
look at it and I cooked something else
good it's good don't worry about it it's
good it's good here what we got here
canned dog food
mm-hmm gross I'm an animal all right all
right so let's soak it I think we're
about 10 more minutes of this one so
okay let's find something to shoot let's
get out into the world and see which way
there's some open space box down there
Fox was a nuclear plant down there too
I'll stumble right in there and just
pick up all this radiation damage find
Delbert winters can you become a ghoul
that's my role is just to be a ghoul I
mean does fast pastime just standing in
the nuclear facility I know nothing in
the mailbox my looting instincts all
right
all right let's fine find something to
kill that isn't let me see what webs are
let me see what weapons I have to cuz I
don't know if I want this shotgun it'll
it right now hi pistol rifle
oh the right one actually which one
there's a level up real quick to you
know a bunch of hunting rifles throwing
knife it's just all strapped here but
what's wrong in this guy oh he just have
four pipe wrenches three packs of blood
and uh okay six rifles the robot what do
you want mister farmhand you want oh no
he's gonna be sorry he was really poor
robot I need you scrap you can sell
nothing lives in this playthrough that
poor farmhand is probably taking care of
like a child
the last thing level like must must save
summer keep summer safe alright
all right are you farmhand
I'll he's back he's alive he's back
protecting children again must save the
orphans Oh God
robot guy oh wait put some fire in it
yeah Oh No Oh baby lot of them all turn
out of them
no that's not a fight I can win you
still won't figure out how to get to uh
my my vats I don't know why I was able
to find them so try left bumper it's uh
yeah you hurt them got a slow gun there
yeah it just you mentioned it but Wow
bad move you whiffed all right how many
left
you're also hurting scorched people all
right I want to step on their bodies
because oh I think you didn't think your
a lot of your you got your hip points
your way that'll pile oh yeah let's see
I guess I got that stimpacks don't do
your heart you're fine probably ah he'll
be okay walk it off West Virginia what's
the speed limit that's just about okay
got it
I'm running faster than that okay
actually if I pull out a camp right here
oh it's green now workplace my camp
you did it can't sight all right press
back to start building
I don't wanna build right now oh but
I'll get lost in the building yeah you'd
only had a couple minutes left we got
clearance on the Dethklok yeah I don't
think that's gonna happen this early on
I mean you never know any scrap today
no just blood got any scraps we lookin
man I'll stick something you seen at
Disney or something
it's so cool all right
I want in this television I just want to
strap it to my wall and stand in front
of it
see okay I think you have to so that's
why it wasn't okay you can only vats
when there's somebody right in front of
you ah she can to look at my oh yeah so
when I was testing it out just like in a
peaceful area with nobody that's why I
won't trigger also my action points are
very low so that's also probably why
they wouldn't show you because I keep
sprinting everywhere what's going on
there
let's tell you a hot dog please all
right
I don't know why I'm whispering I'm like
took his beer bottle it's like that was
mine sure if I wanted wine nice those
little lunch pail it's a good lunch
solid lunch wine thirty somewhere damu
Emran and the chat what games are you
guys playing right now Jack and Trevor I
am still playing Assassin's Creed
Odyssey on my personal account I've got
about 42 hours in my personal account
right now and then you had that on the
Red Dead I think from there and then of
course minecraft always going back to
something I am knee-deep in Red Dead
Redemption - right now how many hours
you put in that that's gonna be like
countless at the moment just like I come
back home from work just jump right into
that world but definitely tried to get
them all fun to guess upwards of 100 for
sure already Wow searching but Natalie
got anything no just pain okay no point
no point in searching you guys go into
that building let's go yeah Oh mo
something just what is happening hold on
oh oh I just felt he's coughed oh okay
vendor bond trader I'd like to trade mr.
robot Brahman hide that's leather though
I need that okay no I'm not here to
trade I'm here to kill
he's like a much higher level with me
but what do you think we'll have a
harness
I'm sorry pass miss is enabled you were
not doing damage to other players did
you tickle my ear yeah uh toilet paper
sorry do you about five minutes more and
then we're gonna switch over to Fort so
that's perfect
Forza horizon for so Jack I don't know
if you noticed but when I picked up the
toilet paper had the magnifying glass
meaning it's made out of a material I am
currently searching for oh that would be
caught so I can make my Patriot outfit
out of toilet paper
and then three more money as well and
also made out of clothes so I think I
have enough cloth if I can I'd have to
go all the way back which I'm probably
fast trouble oh good call you might be
able to obviously just can't fast travel
five caps why not you know what I sold
that coffee cup that I stole just for
this moment worth it for them half what
will be the currency of the future hmm
so this one is extrapolate out of like
their past so bottle caps what's
something that's prolific now that is
almost junk but will survive into the
future I think it's gonna be cell phone
cell phones pictures for their dinners
there are warehouses of fitness bears
okay where this was the private all
right
let's craft all right you're a medic gum
paramedic outfit light armor or outfits
that's what it was there we go Patriot
suit made out of money in toilet paper
I'll just put that thing on and see what
it looks like I think I wrap it up from
there
yes no that's why everyone's apparel
haha right see how you look yes I'll
look at you master Patriot with a party
hat nice to do some emotes oh yeah here
we go uh America loves you I love Z and
hey come on bring it on come to the
party cool yeah I can feel this being a
game that we're gonna sink a lot of how
I got to this is a boy first little
little dabble in just poker chips
already getting hooked yeah alright
getting back into the controls and the
mechanics and stuff see how the
multiplayer shakes out yeah I do
let's kick it over - we do we're got to
talk about this awesome TV you guys been
playing on this is the Samsung 2018 Q
LED TV take a look at this so let's just
tell you a little bit more about it it's
got 4k HDR so you can get the most out
of your console and graphics free sync
which is also called variable refresh
rate this is so that it matches the
framerate of your game so no more screen
tearing or stuttering while you play
which is awesome motion rate 244 more
precise control it's also got that low
input lag so it's more responsive and
auto game mode so that's really useful
for me because it automatically switches
to the best game settings on its own for
you
so if that's something for you this is
the Samsung 2018 Q LED TV brought to you
by Samsung and we're checking out some
games on the Xbox one X so we played
some Assassin's we played some Fallout
76 and now we're gonna close out the
stream with 30 minutes of forts so
what's rising for rising for a game
where I can live out my dreams my
favourite supercar right in the tree
yeah and I was confused cuz I was in
England and like should I should I be on
this side of the road yeah it's funny
I'm actually going I'm going to London
literally this what I leave here it's
gonna be fun so I'll be driving these
cars I'll be in
boobers of various Prius or there's no
need like super uber yeah where you can
get a Pagani or something alright so
we're gonna pick up so again this is a
save game that we don't know so we're
gonna jump right into it and see what we
got and there's a pretty car I would
love to drive through some autumn
villages
no but there's experience the different
seasons yeah I'm pumped man cuz force
has always had amazing visuals cuz
that's one thing like skin texture still
difficult to get right but metals have
they've done pretty much perfectly you
know the majority of car commercials you
see on TV now are actually CGI I'm not
looking in a real I would
as a fact but visually like looking at
it I would not know it's pretty wild
Jorgen asks what are your guys's dream
cars in car man
I think like this classic yellow
Ferraris you see like the exposed engine
in the back yeah those are always be so
are you are you that's a good question
then are you uh between two of them like
there's a many different supercars and
luxury cars and sports cars and stuff
but of the two kind of like more
household name like between Ferrari and
Lamborghini what would you consider
Lamborghini is pretty sweet they're
silly car Aventador is a beautiful car
but I still love the Ferrari Berlinetta
yeah yeah probably one of the last 12
cylinder cars that well I got to say the
Tesla has a new roadster coming out the
2020 roadster I think that looks pretty
sick gorgeous check your dream car and
your dream house and you're doing
whether it's exactly it's where I live
explode what does that how does opens
all the doors Oh see this is where you
put your groceries when you take here
your Lamborghini to the grocery store as
one never saw oh look at that license
plate
look at that branding that was totally
in the game all right
let's drive this bad boy oh gosh okay
and we're going to not gonna auction it
how about that the the m5 the old 1988
BMW m5 BMWs oh you used to be so boxy
and there oh god I'm not a fan of the
old BMWs but now beamers now sharp
looking cars oh man I got it I gotta get
the first person like oh god okay how do
I get back okay I know the snow lands on
the windshield oh that's amazing well
this is just dangerous yeah let's keep
it in first gear why don't you just kind
of slip around Oh Oh what did I hit up
on the d-pad
oh it's photo mode
let's take a nice beautiful picture of
you with your son
Wow through the landscape
okay I see you get that depth on look at
that that's snow beautiful cosmetic
reset cosmic okay now cancel that won't
get to that when you hit your first tree
ho look at that look at that beautiful
shot right yeah this is before yeah
before I absolutely destroy this like
how you feel like you look like you're
doing - driving fast over the 50 I'm
intentionally sliding sideways on this
thing so Labor's haters fence don't mind
me as long as you avoid the trees we're
good
landscaping I like that oh I can exit
nice car yeah I'll look I'm gonna deal
I'm gonna Don Quijote this thing go
right for the window what's in the
bottom left that you got chatting yeah
Anna and what it what is an honest a I
wanna race I need influence
I need informants for it
[Music]
windmill windmill donkey all day almost
got it almost there so close just like
we avoid the living the drift expose the
grass from the eat oh oh man oh man
perfect things over to your right I saw
like a marker I don't you find it
actually good stuff is that roadway when
Beauty spot oh let's get a nice picture
with your cracked car in the beauty spot
also its left bumper to change camera
there yeah there we go beautiful that
was very quick to clean - not so very
yeah okay it's okay well there's a
little buff out little buff out it's got
a little bit of windmill on it so you
said left bumper wall no you lied right
over there oh that that is like imagine
if you were driving a car and you had to
wear goggles that put your vision to the
very front bumper so you're looking out
the middle in front of your car
I'd be terrified
looking for Sasquatch necessarily the
Sasquatch we were looking for no still
destroyer vehicles though alright she
and me I've even seen my ability to
drive yeah looking for my ability to
drive so this is a manual or a England
automatic
they : shot said now that
any of you played any of the NASCAR
games I had an aspir game a long time
ago but I think I played to an orthodox
and that was i play bumper cars and i
would you know pit pit maneuver people
it was not the way the NASCAR way I
usually like open-world racing games
kind of like hoes cuz then is a lot of
the Sunset Drive to your heart's content
looks like you away too so whatever I
don't get a scar too much
oh you have f1 in Austin which is pretty
cool so I'm just kind of neat to watch
those guys yeah I'm from Indiana so I'm
more bright on Indy Racing but then
coming out of like an amazing
definitely got a film degree you can get
on this little pilot induced
oscillations that's exactly what I call
turn right oh yes yeah later take you
where you go she's British - Lana knows
what's up all right here we go - listen
she's taking you to a good breakfast
spot did your destination they call
missing something no what does that a
beauty spot well maybe that's what it is
she's taking you all the good-looking
spots to put your cracked window you
check what's this what's this here knows
oh man obviously that achievement like a
little piece is a lightning bolt here at
the church oh yeah
[Music]
praying and stuff driving outside taking
their snowman out go into a frown when
you wreck the ball that's right I came
in like that so good work that well I
Jack I gotta say I love your pop
references from Ke$ha to Miley Cyrus
yeah modern pop all right I feel bad
like you're you roll again I round do
some damage
go find uber uber Irish back roads
Moorish back just like you would take
your Lavery landscaping who wanted that
trouble my god there's something to your
left is it new
I wanted to get up to speed and I
thought the path kept going again just
ripped it out nice gets more influence
that way I definitely influence somebody
with that there's goober goober ich fat
fatso all right mr. so you got something
there new something there on a stunt
driver and I'm gonna get me polling here
the horses we park it behind that gym
I'll be fine nice honey's daughter keeps
going and so it's very realistic
oh there you go hit X continue alright
alright horizon story here we go
solo yeah next chapter obviously here we
go already some story mode we don't even
serious now we're giving the narrative
that it's for to the real excitement yes
you are right to take your car there
Carla you're at the stunt vehicle yet
you'll understand when you see it good
I'll get some music playing get some
action
I'm too used to like handbrake turns I
think a is yes and right I'm using it
but I'm like I'm absolutely gonna drift
out yeah it's not like Gary
right keep your arrows yellow or green
trust in the arrows alright so it looks
like it's the you're driving on the left
side of the road you were asking about
the earlier I invent my own laws not
going down oh you're crazy
see there's the destinations you know
all right a shortcut we're going through
route and I did I am found
[Music]
well you are a stunt driver this is a
stunt driver mission
you know how to drive stick I drove my
father owned a tractor for a while like
he used to mow soccer fields like like
you found the tracker from some guy for
nothing so it was a stick it was manual
and so I learned how to drive stick on a
tracker but far as cars go no idea I had
a couple friends that had manuals and I
figured even be a good life skill to
just go ahead and pop in a manual cuz I
think a certain point you need to when
you're valeting cars can you hop into
the manual so I thought cars for summer
and uh I I didn't have too much trouble
I haven't done I haven't driven manual
like for like a day to day kind of thing
so I can't sit here and say oh yeah I
definitely manual but um but I could if
I needed to in a pinch I picked up
pretty naturally I might know how to go
the American Way which is just the wrong
way just roundabout it's short perfect
but I I feel like I just get too
stressed out thinking about all the
moving parts I just I really take
advantage of the blog shift on blood
yeah
I have a Tesla now so I only have one
year so there's no facts yeah just on or
off oops
[Music]
my nose here took out their power
that's gonna take a while to fix all
right there's destination your clothes
check this floor it all the way here
yards away I don't know what's gonna
stop here we gonna make it stop for 20
make a lane out of whatever yeah it's
like all right I'm gonna go take it I
Drive by Lambos which is my land
yeah get out of the way we've got a
destination not exceeding the damage
left all right so you got to do this
good so don't ruin okay this is the is
there a time there's a time 2 minutes
and 20 seconds okay you're you're poor
models are basically squirrelly and
stuffy squirrely this looks like German
it takes a cufflink are just so you're
going 140 I got approached to point it
I'll keep an eye on your meter for you
I'll be your rally driver over there
yeah yeah yeah we got a slight left
coming up sir okay light left turn
good call good call way through all the
way through so go to the left for the
chat right now there's gonna be a left a
little bit more okay all right good all
right straight away stray that we've
done it straight away got it okay left
for the check is like right by one
slight slight left right right you're
right that's right excited about being
left going 140 doing very degrees of the
turn oh sorry you've got about a five
degree turn on the right come on over
left button right straight
know about it it definitely didn't make
I think I started going too fast and had
no time to break for that yeah yeah that
was a retrial Jack yeah you'll do your
best not to smash into the back oh man I
gotta respect the sport total scope
points earned nine Lauren said is this
just Top Gear the video K I think Jeremy
Clarkson is you know just smashing in a
start
I think Richard Hammond is the one that
crashes what was it the Reliant Robin
was that the three-wheeled vehicle yes I
think it but if we have some time after
this mission some see what we have at
our disposal we might start around town
the Reliant Robin was a three-wheeled
vehicle had just one single wheel two
front two in the back my god but it was
like top-heavy so if he made like a turn
too sharp you just roll it constantly
was it Jerry Clarkson who just like was
just driving around and literally just
roll it over bit up can you help me and
people would come flip it back over
forms like thank you nice to meet ya
it's probably the funniest bit so it
looks like at this rate I'm going about
yeah plenty a mile and a half in a
minute uh-uh you got two minutes love so
I'm kind of feathering the throttle yeah
just try not to smash into the back of
minivan you know they're tough to see as
they're giant white vans but other guys
still here red man this time they it's
like I'm gonna get a red paint job I'm
tired of getting hit by historical f1
cars it's pretty castle I should I need
to be taking notes right now so this is
where I'm going like literally in like
12 hours I'll be here do you think I
pull over
nice quick picture get some fish and
chips get some fish and chips I got a
minute left you got a point eight miles
doing really well all right it's like 30
seconds to go at this pace just don't
snap house be going to a lighthouse what
watch car so hit the lighthouse yeah
doing some classic music here this is
probably your royalty-free right right
you two don't shut us down please
appreciate that
Lauren in the chat have you ever wrote
off shortly oh no what was the first car
you ever bought from Allison I had a
1976 Chevy Nova it was it was a beast of
a car I loved that I bought it for a
hundred bucks cuz the engine was cracked
and so my dad and I fixed it got it had
a 305 inch engine in it had a it was an
8 cylinder engine and the Nova's were
back in the early 70s era racer there
were more sporty cars and by the 80s
they became family cars this was in the
middle of it where it was a giant muscle
family car had two full bench seats in
it and I could feel like eight people in
the car I put flowmasters on it so I
just had this great rumble of an engine
and it was two-tone like peach and white
and it was just a beautiful car I loved
that car so much and then eventually the
the head of it cracked again it was
gonna cost like 2 grand to fix and I'm
like it's not worth it and so the
festival site are you traveling to a fan
we're going to a festival about
festivals I want to see my car car car
or master easy
Martin though you track my cards here we
go here's our car that means we have 16
cars and I mean who doesn't own a
Reliant Robin just right out of the gate
to answer the question why we look here
I'll be honest my first car I didn't buy
it cuz I just inherited it was a 93
Cadillac deville so it was a boat of a
car nice but man that thing was a heavy
tank yeah so it doesn't look what we
have it Howie can drive just enjoy than
a 4 right I believe so
it's a coupe Avant what am I gonna take
around town 18 there are 1985 forwarding
that you drive the fortnight or that
Mustang when I go for a county or deck I
don't get in that car so this car is a
lot of carbon fiber and Jeremy's got a
2018 Mustang right really nice when you
open the door it shines the logo of the
Mustang on them like on the sidewalk
it's so silly this car well it's it's
got a really glittery oh look at that
camera work and by that I mean sleet on
your hold on a second stunt driver let's
see is there a map here and there we go
what do we want to look for yeah that's
in front of race like one of those in
between the ages yeah both side ascent
so that's a street race okay what's that
closer to you right go up by the
hospital what's this oh oh there you go
that one's been done already so Broadway
windmill what are they for the hospital
is here I see if we're playing Forza
horizon for on the Xbox one X we're
playing on the Samsung 2018 Q LED TV and
who you're looking at right now yeah
that's the TV right there it's 75 inches
and we were talking about it before it's
got a 4k HDR and free sync motion or a
240 auto game mode all that good stuff
and the people playing right now we
currently have Trevor Collins playing
but we are also joined by deck the two
though they're both from Achievement
Hunter
hanging out for just about 650
these cars I kick about 15 60 more
minutes some beautiful forts absolutely
just driving your gold-plated yeah just
cards yes fronts looking it's okay it's
okay I do like about these like
supercars in these games though is that
the torque is so powerful like if you
want to turn around just floor it
yeah and turn and they'll they'll donut
around for you Oh
mr. snowman I missed a snowman that's so
different
I'll see you immediately go to the right
side of the road with my rear view
mirror five years reach out their hand
and smack Oh God it's it's hard to tell
that I'm even going 130 yeah that's like
that's like realistic too because I I've
you're never if you're in a car like not
like this I've never been in a car like
this but if you're in a sporty car they
can get up to speed and it does not feel
like you are up to speed at all oh hey
Dad sorry
I didn't mean to be here all right
should we try something yeah look at
that
that's a bumper in their change car it
depends on what we're this is fine I'm
just gonna yeah I can compete in this if
I'm just gonna be okay and let go with
this car
I was you dance oh she's enjoying this
car she's guy I would to dance dance now
this is like a supercar for sure the
windows as you can see are made out of
plastic every pound or as they would say
every kilo that they can cut to make
weight incredibly important you think
there's any cup holders in this one if
we don't get anybody quickly all going
well it's it's counting now a cup
holders very American ask of you Jack
doubt it
it's bucket seats and metal floor do you
think you should feel like you please
roll up to McDonald's like I'm sorry
that I can't roll the windows down
they're plastic yeah like the burger
give me my McRib and fries there we go
I like that the doors were open both
will go into so Logan horizon presents
well it's all the answers she's never
stopped well we wait do you guys have
any guilty pleasure movies that's a good
question
oh man um I'm a sucker for romantic
comedies I was gonna say the same thing
Jack so
[Music]
the one I've been watching a lot
recently speaking of England was me
before you with with Emilia Clarke I
love her my wife and I both agree that
she is she we both want to marry her so
she'll be you know our art our wife oh
man I started late I think I was waiting
for a countdown you guys are own hair
watch me he's putting in the wall yeah I
would go with that right now it's it's
such a sad movie I'm watching it's happy
but it sounded like you know my guilty
pleasure movies are like some old 90s
meg Ryan movies like City of Angels or
you've got mail angel speaking of Nick
Cage like and I think that one is
especially because the Goo Goo Dolls do
this yeah Irish music music man I
connect to music so like that that'll
pull it to you and yeah yeah I
definitely associate like certain songs
with movies and that sometimes makes me
like the song yep like there you go mix
poison good guy 10 Things I Hate About
You
let's get another good one perhaps being
a wallflower not necessarily rom-com but
I really enjoyed that movie I like you
know I like feel-good movies and I like
movies that kind of make you think but
like but also feel yes it's nice to feel
things but there you go really funny way
up ice DJs and funny yeah I always love
the fake gamertags again
yeah you know I mean poach occasionally
now it's stuck great clean racing yep
do this rather what's your guilty
pleasure nice the crisper Lambert was
was reading the paper and a girl from
Billy Madison is Sonya
Bridget Wilson Sandra's small world
honey laughs three quarters there Trevor
alright last laugh you see I lost my
side mirror on the right really you can
just turn your head back around a look
he needs it's okay cuz in the same vein
of Top Gear you know looking forward is
but are ya looking what is it looking
good is better than looking where you're
going
so I'm just very tuned in to this rare
doing great you're doing good I'm very
calm doing you're doing the what is it
what's the term getting sweaty right now
is that the best new thing I'm getting
sweaty I think so that's what though the
49ers are saying now is like I'll get
sweat this one out I'll getting sweaty
my pool is what it is I'm sold
okay jack okay you got this awesome
clean racing there's the finish gun it
spin out actually blended really well
into first wow that's pretty cool for
you into the Atrix long Irish axe came
about a second later or no no four
seconds later almost crushed take his
face John whoo John was just throwing
thumbs and things good look at your road
racing five now and you got a modern
supercars T level 11 like the 90s you
just standing in this creepy white room
with this giant screen is that Nic Cage
Scotsman nice Boilermakers you can go
watch what was it produce yeah that's my
that's my university there you go
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful cars on PI's pants and if all
we're gonna spend the next 15 minutes
just dressing that's gonna be it it's a
billion miles away though yeah catch
train a window and borough Jack well you
don't know what I'm gonna go to
Edinburgh this is great I want you to
wake you mr. Oliver Loch Ness so I'm
taking the train to right about there do
you know try this out wait how do I get
to that six and half miles isn't gonna
take it's gonna take a couple minutes
though let's see world map wait all
right where was the train oh yeah I'm
going there to go to Castle you can you
can see where I'm going to go Alana's
talking to me there's a train station in
the middle of a city on the old one
don't you see faster now purchase
treasure man
alright what do I see influence boards
that route thought I saw a fast travel
but maybe I maybe that's read something
maybe the houses or something hard
there's a lightning bolt like maybe
those lightning bolts okay okay maybe
not maybe have to go and you have to go
to another one to get to there look for
it look for one yeah that's what I was
looking for cuz there's a train station
to get up there up north
alright alright lightning bolt
might be so exciting below this one yeah
I go hit that one let's see it
alright here we go turn around here
perfect else do you like a Christmas
story oh shoot your eye out because it's
unlike
TBS every year yeah here's a fun fact so
do you know the name of the kid from
Christmas Story the name is Peter
Billingsley he is friends with Jon
Favreau and he's an elf
so the kid from a Christmas tree he is
the elf in the North Pole when he's like
Oh buddy let's see how many you made
like oh you made 300 he's like ooh like
that one that's the guy he's got like a
goatee glasses
his eyes are shockingly blue have you
see him it's like oh my god that's the
kid and he's actually a producer like he
helped produce Iron Man and do it watch
that but him and John four or like
everybody else
I'm your small world what are you doing
look it's it's right here so there's a
man coming hello hi hello cleaner her
mine they get closer by foot okay okay
whoa
it's a cost action what is that that oh
you can see his stuff you gonna make the
convoy join his convoy it's too late now
how do I don't take it look like it's
right here you're going to see the lack
of it I don't see it on now like in the
world is he in there mini-map well
there's like I can't pan up but there's
a like a oh is there maybe press Start
you're back Oh fireworks that there's
fireworks
whoa a lot of fireworks alright now how
do i okay bust the table out of the way
since she's going yeah I need some I
need some need a pint and some fish and
chips actually nobody's taking a pie you
can get back in the car
alright alright alright I'm gonna just
gonna have to I'm gonna have to drive
myself yeah we got we got about we have
about a little less intense
eight minutes left eight minutes will be
a man go find those fireworks how about
that go figure out where this might be
where I just came from to be honest but
I can't say no to fireworks left
okay go that it's it's fine the railroad
tracks oh why are you doing this why I
like that every game we've played it
ended at night nice for the the HDR yeah
make it see those fireworks oh I'm here
for the festivities as I come oh yeah
it's gonna picture hold on
pardon pardon whoops I think you want
some lights think you hit up to get the
photos here we go
is it you yeah I think it's up to get on
the d-pad to get a photo oh then maybe
that's what I was missing for yeah
fascinating yeah there it is a ferris
wheel
there's no way let's see
Ferris was shot a fire thing to be gone
Alex pretty and then if you hit I think
up and down be Pat or maybe the triggers
I'll do like the foot the zoom resetting
cosmic Emily reset the cosmetics I
didn't hit anything try tracking the
triggers
up and down there you go that is this it
pulls the fisheye all right I'm not at a
great angle not a lot of light look
she's spiking the lens camera actually
that's that's yeah find a better spot
let's figure out seaming it airborne so
you can do it while you're good call
like see we can pop off something just
skillfully for taking a photo those all
those people so even a photo with the
people take a selfie let's look for
anything with an upward direction so I
can like
launched
I like the music I was making with
landscaping stuff all right now this is
a track so it's gonna be very flat
around yeah it's gonna be a quarter
million dollar car unless you just ran
off the side of it all right let's get
some motion and see where the windmills
at or rather the ferris wheel
oops not close enough you can reset the
damage yeah so we smash it it's clean up
your car before you take a photo let's
see oh there's the Hollywood Tower
repair that's just a castle
well I think I think we should get out
to the castle and that's where we'll end
if we can make it in time where does the
castle right that's it's gonna be in
right yeah sure let's go there no I mean
well you'll probably spot it okay okay
just hold public let's see well but yeah
five minutes Trevor you can do this we
got it I believe you seven seven whales
averaging like eighty miles an hour on
the way we'll be fine
pay your ticket book just throw some
Cougars out cuz I left her there you
know we actually did a ghost hunt out in
areas that would kind of like this room
too that it was amazing
went to a place out in London we have a
convention two large X I love Austin for
the first time we do one in London and
after the one in London was over we
we're doing a show called sheep at
Hunter it's currently on on Rashid calm
go check that out and we filmed one for
season two and a place out in near
London was a West Wycombe I think was
the name of the city um
I don't recall the the particular
neighborhood or like village area but it
was it was creepy as hell
there's near Sussex right well we did
what it was an East Sussex East Sussex
that was it
because the West Wycombe one I think no
yeah we shot - oh thanks honor so I
think that I think the seasons actually
work out we're like it'll get brighter
just taking a little bit of the road
it's all good alright there we go
going in five and a half miles you can
do this we'll find a pretty location in
Edinburgh take a photo we'll take a
photo and wrap it up it's like the sun's
coming up for a beautiful photo bringing
out
I'm afraid there's gonna be a sharp turn
some way or just a car don't worry
because I'm going 217 miles an hour its
ultimate speed there you go that's a
quick stop that took my eye off the road
for just a second to see my my speed
bowl and to check if it was kilometres
an hour of miles now has miles and it
was it's not the speed that'll kill you
it's the sudden stop that'll kill you
that's that's what gets you alright are
four miles away and you're going 140 150
so if they're pretty awesome wind
turbines do those things are all over
West Texas mm-hmm I drove through there
I took a road trip out to Denver from
Austin there's a lot of winter lines I
discovered another area there's a bunch
up in northern Indiana as well that they
like I don't remember them being there
too much but when I was going to college
but they they went up pretty quick so if
you're driving from Indianapolis to
Chicago you will see a lot I cool
there's so big - yeah and a night
they'll flash red yeah
looks like an alien perfect doesn't
respond as well as a mental every yoke
and roundabouts okay Hardin hope there's
nothing that's okay
I'm meant to be oh dude I won't even get
a photo smashing through the side oh
don't worry Bucky just keep going be
able to smash something on location oh
there's there's a there's a cat it's up
the castle I don't know I know this is
what can like it now I stopped I think
that might be the castles like a castle
yeah it's up on the hill yeah that's it
that's the castle so go right and then
go yeah go up the hill so even get into
like the castle for like yeah yeah
that's it so there's actually this
castle the castle in Denver is the
castle that JK Rowling based Hogwarts on
oh yeah that's it's a hard percent yeah
I think people take a lot of photos
there yeah there's actually there's a
school at the base of the castle that
looks up at the castle and the school
and this is this is on the road this is
the Royal Mile I've literally I've been
on this room this is
this is where I'm going this is where I
will definitely have to reset cosmetics
but I met a roosterteeth fan who work
right here I'd like that date on the
left
yeah that's really cool okay and then to
the right you wear down is weird some
damage in here and then take just
knocking over trash bins and stuff yeah
well turn around real quick before we
they have a big cannon that they fire
off thing at one o'clock every day it's
like the Honda in Cannon or something it
is really cool very cool all right all
right photo mode okay get yourself a
nice photo of the castle reset that lets
see you sir good show nice feet oh look
at that you can like change no no I
don't exit I'll go to fat let's see cuts
down oh look at that trying to reset the
cosmetics out oh there we go slept
bumper beautiful thanks Pat and then
there we go if I can pull it that's nice
that's good all right there we go dude
that's awesome good job driver thank you
Jeff you made it to Edinburgh I made it
to Scotland you'll see Mary Queen of
Scots I've taken you to Edinburgh now
you will take yourself now I'm gonna go
there I'll be there yeah next week sir
recreate this photo carnal yeah I'll
stake my take my gold-plated sadbhir I'm
sure you written one of those yeah for
sure
all right so before we close that let's
take one more look at the cue LED TV so
let's cut to some b-roll so we've been
playing xbox one x games on the Q LED TV
as you see here by Samsung it's got 4k
HDR so you can get the most out of your
console in graphics
free sync which matches framerate of
your game so no more screen tearing or
stuttering while you play which is very
exciting
motion rates 240 for more precise
control you've got the low input lag so
it's more responsive also that auto game
mode so you can automatically switch to
the best gaming settings on its own for
you super convenient thank you so much
guys for coming by and playing some
games on the Xbox one next how was your
experience oh this is awesome yeah this
TV is is great I wish I had one of these
for my house
so I'm sure what the Samsung to hook us
up
it's type it type in this code on the
website and you'll get one now this is
gorgeous I wish I had something like
this yeah thanks for having us out had a
blast yeah yeah thank you guys so much
it's so much fun
we'll see you guys next time yeah bye
bye guys
you